Maybe a little bit more preparation on this slide.
Also another factor is because of my injury on my toe.
Perfect, I think.
That's it, you did so well.
Oh my gosh, John.
Wait, just keep an eye out on my email.
I'm going to send you a complete report and also a copy of your performance, both of them.
Yes, sounds good.
That's amazing.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
Which part was amazing?
How did you feel?
I think...
You can continue watching it because we cannot pause it.
We have to begin.
This one was...
This one, the beginning movement is my most...
It's like the thing where I can know like what's my...
How's my body doing?
This is the routine.
This one is good.
It was better than I thought because
I was worried that
I didn't have enough running space to start running before I jump.
But actually it was okay and it was enough to do a good one.
But usually I did something a little bit more extra where you only saw one kick after the scissor.
Usually you have to do two or three.
Spin kick, I didn't want to go crazy because I know I will fell because of the math situation and my injury.
So...
Yeah.
The movement and flow, like the basic movements here,
I was happy and I'm happy with how it looks.
Because a few days ago when I was injured and competing, it didn't look that good.
I think today I had prepared really well condition-wise.
My body was happy and they were not mad at me for
overtraining yesterday.
But yes, overall, it was a great experience.
I'm impressed.
Super impressed.
Good job.
I think if someone like Ivan or Emily, they're really light compared to me.
I'm a little bit heavy.
Not heavy for mine, but heavy for Hunsei.
So this fact was a little...